International crime syndicates have
elevated their business into a booming
global economy doc money goods and
services are Crossing Borders like never
before
criminal entrepreneurs use next-gen
social profiling to recruit from all
walks of life offering irresistible
opportunity for personal riches radical
belief or Twisted pleasure
this approach creates the ultimate
distributed organizational structure
almost impossible to unravel a spreading
cancer of ordinary people and doing
unspeakable things no one is above
suspicion made up of autonomous cells
they are everywhere all but impossible
for law enforcement to do anything about
clients looking for justice are lining
up but with no names to the contracts so
this time a little more footwork is
needed 47th rmo is to identify trusted
Syndicate members take them out and
analyze the ripples in their digital
Footprints with enough input we'll be
able to track down the leaders and shut
down the syndicates one at a time
I'll leave you to prepare